DAN GALPIN: We're actually
deviating from our schedule.
You were going to be
hearing from Tim Murray, who
was going to give an
amazing talk on in-depth
of how to use systrace.
But before you hear
that, you're going
to hear from me, who's
going to give a much less
exciting and technical talk
about new Android features
that are important for
games, or at least that's
what it says in the schedule.
That's actually going to
be covered by this talk,
but you know, the truth
is what I realized is,
as I was coming up with
this talk, that most of you
are not all that interested
in new Android features.
Because basically you're
interested in targeting
90% of the devices out there,
and the new Android features
are going to be on a fairly
small amount of them.
So what I really should do is
come back to you in like a year
and be like, OK, here are
the new Android features.
And as soon as I can actually
find my mouse pointer
on one of these screens-- there.
It's there.
That's incredible.
Somewhere it thinks
this monitor is hiding.
Gotta love it.
All right, there we are.
OK, good.
That's where I thought it was.
All right, so instead of
actually talking about this,
what I'm actually
going to talk about
is migrating your
established game
to target Android O and beyond,
and why is this actually
relevant to you.
Well, I don't know how many
people actually saw this,
but back about
six months ago, we
announced that all apps
and games on Google Play
will have to target the latest
SDK version of about a year ago
in order to be able to
continue updating on Play,
and all new titles
have to actually target
SDK 26 or higher as of August if
they want to be on Play at all.
And you'll notice if you
upload something today,
you'll actually get a warning
that looks like this that
says exactly what I put here.
So you don't have to read it.
So the real question is,
what does this actually mean?
OK, first of all, let's go
over the real basics of what
SDK versions are,
and that SDK version
is the lowest version your
app is going to support,
and you usually tie
this into this grid
of what the latest device's
platform distribution is like.
The compile SDK is literally
the headers and libraries
that the app links against,
and the target SDK version
is this really
important one, and this
is the platform's
way of ensuring
backwards compatibility.
And this really
says to the world,
I have tested my game on
this platform release.
And what happens
is the system only
applies certain kinds
of behavior changes
to target these
specific SDK versions.
And so technically,
your compile SDK
needs to be at least as great
as your target SDK and minsdk,
but usually, obviously,
you're actually
thinking about wanting
to target a very
large swath of the ecosystem.
So you're actually going
to make the compile
SDK equal to the target
SDK version, which
is going to be much greater
than the minimum SDK version.
All right, that was
probably confusing.
And it impacts a
whole bunch of things.
If you haven't gone
beyond, let's say, M,
you have to deal with changes
in runtime permissions--
so AlarmManager,
manifest-declared
BroadcastReceivers, and
background services.
And you might be saying,
OK, well, look, I'm
using one of these.
I don't care about
this stuff at all.
They're just going to handle
all that for me, right?
I mean, how is this relevant?
You're talking about
hand-writing APIs
to a bunch of game developers.
Well, first of all,
there's a possibility
that you might have something
else beyond that in your app.
And these things might not
be compatible with the latest
version of Android.
And so you have to look
at all of these plugins,
and what they do, and how
they are impacting things.
And of course, it's very
possible we will also
have to update the version
of the platform for one
of those two big things,
which can be a lot of work.
So let's talk a little
about runtime permissions.
If you're still targeting L,
which hopefully most of you
aren't, this is something
you'll have to deal with.
And this is actually
really good.
I think Runtime Version is
one of the best things we ever
did because it allows you to
ask for sensitive permissions
in context.
And not all
permissions are runtime
ones, just this really simple
and easy-to-remember list.
But the good news is that that's
not the way the user sees it.
Users actually
see it like this--
so calender, phone,
camera, sensors, contacts.
None of you guys ever need
any of this stuff, right?
And of course, just because your
game isn't yet targeting M--
admittedly this is
not a game, but it's
an example of something
that doesn't yet
target M. The user can
still go on these devices,
and they can shut
all that stuff off.
So it's still good to actually
understand how this works,
because--
and you might think, all
right, well, this is easy.
What I'm going to do is just
prompt all of these things
right up front, right
when my game starts.
I'll have, like, five
permissions that I'm
going to go ask for it.
And this is a really good
way to make someone never
run your game again.
They're like, why does it want
to have access to my contacts
right now?
That makes no sense.
That's really scary.
Go away.
So if it only needs the camera
permission when it's actually
doing some cool
stuff with AR mode,
then ask for the camera
permission then, OK.
It's really, really important.
I know there's some
work involved here,
but it's so important
when someone getting
the first impression of your
game, the first thing you see
is, like, I want to
know all about you
and everything you do.
So another thing with that that
is going to change is alarms.
And alarms are actually
my favorite APIs,
because it's just hilarious.
Now they take two
different forms.
They have literal
alarms, and we have
schedulers for background work.
And this was
originally really how
you did background
work on Android
in early versions of it.
You would schedule an alarm,
or you would wake up your app
in the future.
And what we decided was
that was a bad thing,
because a lot of apps were all
waking up at the same time,
or even waking up
at various times,
and it wasn't allowing us to
prioritize system resources
well.
So back in KitKat we decided,
OK, we're going to make it
so the alarms, by
default, are not exact
unless they're
explicitly requested.
And this is all stuff that
only happens if your target SDK
version changes.
So we've added this
thing called, well, set
means that it will
happen around the time
that you said it
would happen, and then
we have set exact,
which means it's really
going to happen at that
time that you really
said it was going to happen.
So this is how APIs evolve.
And the thing is
that this is actually
code from the Support Library.
So if you're using
Support Library,
you have to care about this.
You call set exact.
On older versions, you call set.
On newer versions,
you call set exact,
and it works the same way.
Now, the alarm manager
then had more changes
when we went to Doze,
which had to happen
in Android M, along with
runtime permissions.
And we realized,
oh, well, now we've
got this problem that the
device could be asleep,
and we're only allowing apps
to run during these maintenance
windows during that time.
So we said, well, set
exact isn't good enough,
because set exact
still isn't going
to fire during these
maintenance windows,
and we now added set exact
and allow while idle.
Just to be really explicit,
we like long function names.
It's very self-documenting,
and these actually
can wake the device from Doze.
And again, here's what
the compatibility story
looks like here.
And once again, there
we are, and it actually
just calls into the previous
function we just showed you
if you're on older versions.
So very, very, very,
very simple, and yes,
this allows you to fire
in the middle of Doze.
You might not want to
do this, because it's
pretty bad for battery
life, but it does give you
a way of doing it.
So after all of
this, if you're going
to be running a bunch of
work in the background,
you probably don't
use alarms at all.
Actually, consider using
like something like--
well, actually, yeah, probably
Firebase Job Dispatcher
at this point, although we've
got some news coming tomorrow.
So stay tuned.
So BroadcastReceivers
also changed,
and these have been
used by the platform
to know if my app is responsive
to system-wide events.
And what a lot of
apps used to do
was they used to hang
around, and you'd say,
oh, I want to wait
for Wi-Fi so I
can download a whole bunch
of stuff in the background
and not actually impact the
data of the user all that much.
Which is good because users,
when they see an app using tons
of data, they un-install it.
So we have like 10 apps all fire
at once as soon as the device
got on Wi-Fi.
You plug the device in, and
then the device would heat up,
and it's a really bad
user experience, honestly.
And whatever they're
doing in the foreground
gets completely trashed.
So we decided this
is a bad thing.
So we said, all right, this
is one of these things that
gave developers great
power, and with great power
comes great responsibility.
And in response to the way
these endpoints were used,
we took all the power away.
So you can't actually
launch the app anymore
when network changes happen.
However, we did actually,
at least once you target O.
Now, the good news is, first of
all, some of these broadcasts
other than network actually
still work because there's
simply no other way to do it.
So if locale changes--
well, a bunch of people
are like, really?
There's a broadcast for
when locale changes?
That's cool.
But yes, when locale
changes or accessories
are attached-- a
lot of these things
are just the kind of thing
that doesn't happen very often.
Boot completed,
you can still use,
so if you need to have
alarms or the things
that you have to register
during that, that still works.
But for the most part,
these don't work anymore.
So for network
broadcasts, however, you
can use JobScheduler,
Firebase JobDispatcher,
or some other things, and that
allows you to actually say,
hey, I want to make sure that
my job gets run when I actually
have network.
This is cool.
You can be downloading new
stuff in the background.
This is what hopefully
all of your SDKs
are using that are
doing things like ads.
If they're not
using this, they're
not going to work really
well when you go and target
Android O.
And this is cool.
You can actually set
all sorts of information
about the network type,
for example, here.
So you can actually
say, hey, I want
to only have this
running when I actually
have network, which is cool.
So it can actually let
you know that there
is a network available, and more
importantly, it can also say,
I only want to run in
unmetered networks, which
is kind of a cool thing.
So you can say, hey--
and you can even do
cool stuff, like, I
want to run on
unmetered networks,
but I want to have a watchdog
that hangs around and says,
if my job hasn't
run within 24 hours,
let's run it anyways--
that kind of thing.
So you have a lot
of options here.
And if you do have
to use something
for backwards compatibility
for an old version of Android,
like have some
connectivity change thing,
one of things that's
really cool is
you can actually
leave it disabled
by default, which is cool.
I didn't even know
you could do this
in earlier versions of Android.
I'm like, oh, that's awesome,
but it's been always there.
And you can actually
then turn it back on.
So you can say,
OK, well, now I'm
on this ancient
version of Android.
Let's turn this back on.
That will allow me to still
be launched on an old version
and still use the old APIs.
Another thing that
people want to know about
is when their package gets
uninstalled and re-installed
with the new version.
That's actually kind
of a useful thing.
And a lot of them
would go and say,
let's look to see all of
the packages on the system.
And when that happens,
and that's really bad--
a lot of apps were
actually doing that.
And so you can no
longer do that,
but you can actually use
MY_PACKAGE_REPLACED to find out
when your own specific package
gets replaced, which is good.
There's also actually
an API if you
do want to find out when other
packages are being replaced
on a regular basis.
You can actually pull for
them with a sequence number.
So you can say, oh,
has anything happened
since the last time I run?
So if you have other
apps that you're
trying to check to see that are
companions to the one you have
or just wanted to check
to see how that's going on
in the system, you can still
do that without actually
having to have your
app wake up every time
another app is installed.
It's much better.
OK, so let's talk about
background limits as well.
This is also something that
has changed with Android O.
Probably the biggest
change is that when
you're in the
background, you can't
do a whole bunch of things.
You can't launch
services anymore.
And this is a big change
for a lot of these SDKs
that just kind of assumed,
oh, I could always do this.
And so what does it really
mean to be in the foreground?
Well, it means your
app is visible.
It means it has a
foreground service.
Foreground service
is that service
that actually has a notification
associated with it all
the time, so the user knows
that it's always running.
Sometimes it may
kind of annoyingly
show up in this thing that's
running in your notification
list.
But it's really important
that it's visible to the user.
Your app is essentially in
the foreground at that point,
or if it's bound to an app
that's in the foreground.
Also, if you're doing one
of these things, which
I don't think any game
developers are using,
except maybe a
wallpaper service,
you're also in the foreground.
And you're in the background
when you're not visible
and when you're not running
a foreground service,
and if you're running
one of these job
things or BroadcasterReceiver.
And if you're running on
O plus, starting a service
in the background throws
an IllegalStateException
if you're targeting O.
So this is a pretty big deal.
This actually affected
some of my code.
And this really
changed the way Android
dealt with running stuff in the
background in a really good way
for users, and a way that
makes things slightly more
challenging for developers.
So you can still
start services that
are running in the
background when
your game is in the foreground.
And those will continue
to run for about a minute
after your game is exited.
And it doesn't mean that
your code stops running.
Remember, Android--
these are hints
to the OS for how to schedule
things more than anything else.
So it doesn't mean that
your app immediately
gets closed after
it gets backgrounded
and that your code stops.
What it does mean,
however, on Android O,
is that you'll actually
lose your wakelocks,
and this happens for everyone.
So once your app no longer has
a running service on Android O,
your wakelocks will
automatically be cut off.
Or if you don't have an
activity, or a service,
or a BroadcastReceiver, or
a content provider running,
your wakelocks get cut off.
And that's actually
a good thing.
We had a lot of
apps that were just
hanging around all the time,
and keeping wakelocks open,
and wasting a lot of battery.
And so this is actually
something that affects you on O
regardless of whether or not
you're actually targeting O.
But on earlier versions you
can keep a service running all
the time, and on O you can't.
And there are still a few cases
where you can actually still
launch background services.
So you can actually do this
when your app is responding
to a notification that the
system still thinks of your app
as being foregrounded.
So that's kind of good.
High-priority Firebase
Cloud message also
is considered being
in the foreground,
and that also wakes
you up from Doze.
So don't use it very
often unless you
have to, like really
important, timely things.
And SMS and MMS delivery,
which hopefully no one here
is going to be that provider.
And then we also have
behavior changes.
And you might not have
noticed these yet,
depending on how
many of your users
are actually running Oreo.
But we have a lot of limits
on background location, which
are good.
This actually is important.
A lot of apps are just
hanging around all the time,
like, where are my users?
And so you can't
do that anymore.
You'll get much less, even
if you request tons and tons
of location updates.
If your app is running
in the background,
it does not have a
foreground service,
then you only get a couple of
results an hour by comparison.
It's actually a
lot more than that,
but it's a lot less than it was.
Even Wi-Fi scans
are actually cached.
So if you keep scanning
Wi-Fi over and over
in the background,
it's only going
to give you a few
updates every hour
by comparison to what
it was doing before.
So you use things
like Geofencing.
For example, if you
need to know when
the user reaches a
specific location,
you can do things like use--
you only have 100 of those.
You can use things like dynamic
geofencing with regions.
These are all
really cool things.
You want to do cool
stuff with your game.
If you want to have
hardware beacons in places,
that's pretty cool, too.
That's another way of
using the nearby APIs.
There's a lot of ways
to get around that.
You use batching if you want
to track people's location.
Hopefully a lot of
games aren't doing this,
but location-based games
are getting more popular
all the time.
So you can just check
this max wait time here,
and that will allow you to
batch location updates for you.
And then you can also
use passive locations.
This fastest interval
here actually
will mean that I'm not
requesting getting updated
all the time with location.
But if someone else
is using Google Maps
or using activity tracking
somehow for sports or something
like that, that I still
get those updates, too.
So it's kind of a cool
way of doing that.
So another thing I
wanted to mention
is that Android
keeps introducing
battery optimizations
that are based
on deferring and restricting
background tasks.
So again, I talked a
little bit about Doze.
This limits app activity
to maintenance windows,
when things are
unplugged or stationary--
that kind of thing.
And then we actually
added Doze on the Go.
I guess that's not really
what we're calling it--
Doze Light.
But it's for when--
it still limits most things
to maintenance windows
when the device is unplugged
and the screen is off, like when
the user's in the pockets.
It does allow for a
few things that aren't
allowed during regular Doze.
And then we also did this
thing called App Standby.
So if someone doesn't
use an app very often,
it starts slowly limiting
what the app can do.
And that's really good
because a lot of--
I install apps that I only use
when I'm in certain places,
and this allows me to make sure
that they're not constantly
draining my battery.
But for a game
developer, it doesn't
mean that if someone is not
using your app all the time,
and you're trying to
do all sorts of stuff
in the background, they'll
stop seeing these things.
And then stay tuned.
We have a lot more
stuff coming in P
that we'll be talking
about tomorrow.
So how do you test these things?
It's pretty straightforward.
You can test Doze this
way using an adb command.
And this allows you to see
how your app actually performs
when it's running in Doze mode.
You can test App
Standby by doing this.
You have to unplug the
battery, but you can do that
with this nice
command that makes
the system think the
battery is unplugged
before you start doing that.
OK, and then I
did mention that I
was going to talk
about modern features
you could take advantage of.
One of things you have
to take advantage of
is notification channels.
Because if you don't have
notification channels,
and you're targeting O, your
notifications don't appear.
They just don't show up.
So you really want
to turn this on.
And this is actually
really cool.
Because if you actually
give the user good channels
and explain this is a really
high-priority notification,
and these are
things you might be
interested in these
categories, it
prevents them from actually
disabling all notifications
to your game.
And so this is
actually something
I definitely recommend really
thinking about and trying
to make a user scenario
where you're like,
OK, well, actually I really
do want to know when there's
a cool free offer
here, but I don't
want to be notified every single
time that one of my friends
comes on--
that sort of thing.
And so you can really make the
user make good choices that
say, you know what?
I don't want to disable all
the notifications for your app,
because the app means
something to me,
but I can actually
use these channels.
So I recommend really
thinking about this.
It actually has helped us, too.
In devices that have
notification channels,
we actually see less people
turning off all notifications.
So it does actually work.
One of things you also
have to think about
is if your app is
using immersive mode.
Or some games actually do
use this translucent status
bar, which is kind of cool.
I wish more did.
You have to think about
this display cutout,
because a lot of apps and games
assume that the status bar was
like 28 density-independent
pixels tall, and turns out
it's not true if you
had these cutouts.
And you can also simulate a
cutout using the P developer
preview image.
So that's useful.
Probably not a lot of things.
Make sure-- probably the biggest
thing for game developers,
actually, that some
games aren't still doing,
is dealing well with long
aspect ratio screens.
This has gotten a
lot better recently.
I can't imagine why.
But I guess long
aspect ratio screens
are getting important--
are getting more common.
But there are still games
that will occasionally
have content that's cut
off, because a lot of people
really think of
things in terms of--
think of the layout
of their HUD in terms
of having a fairly limited
set of aspect ratios.
So this is something it's
definitely worth testing for,
and these are going to be
even more common this year.
You can letterbox
things if you want.
Another thing I haven't
seen any games doing,
but I'm sort of waiting
for it, is actually
supporting picture in picture.
Obviously people
use it for chat,
but I'm sort of waiting
for some-- especially--
I mean, honestly I want
Pokémon Go to do this,
because it would be kind of
awesome to have my little
Pokémon character running around
in the corner while I'm doing
other things.
So I put it there.
Also, we do have Vulkan.
Think of taking advantage of it.
These are the new changes
that are in Vulkan 1.1, which
is actually part of Android P,
which were finally implementing
multi-view, which I'm
really excited about.
For VR we also have
all the memory models
that are necessary to have much
better compatibility with HLSL;
shaders, which is cool if
people who are sharing those;
as well as some cool
things for video processing
and for open CLC compatibility.
So again, there's a lot
of cool stuff there.
So consider using Vulkan.
Another thing that I
really, really like--
and this isn't part of
P. This was actually
added in Android O, is AAaudio,
which is our new audio API.
It's really
straightforward to use--
really simple by
comparison to using OpenSL.
And the best part
about it is we actually
have this library called Oboe
that wraps AAudio and wraps
OpenSL, turns and uses one API.
With AAudio, you
also can get access
to something called
sharing mode exclusive,
which actually gives you super,
super, super low latency.
So it's really for
hardcore rhythm games.
It gets you down to
sub-10-millisecond output
on devices that support it--
at least our devices.
And it's pretty cool.
I definitely recommend
taking a look at Oboe.
Here's a project you can go to.
Oh, yeah.
There is one more thing
that we did in Android P
that I wanted to make
sure that you knew about,
and that is that we actually
got rid of the ability
to call most private APIs.
Now, if you've been following
us, we actually, in the NDK,
we stopped people from calling
most private APIs in Android O.
In Android P, we
actually stopped people
from calling most
of the APIs that
are running in the native
sort of Java level.
And there actually are quite
a few that are still allowed.
We're in the process of
trying to go through the SDK,
make sure that all
the things that
are really useful and
relevant and not scary
are turned into proper APIs,
and so that we're trying really
hard not to actually
hurt people's
functionality with this.
But what I want everyone
to do is test your game
on the Developer Preview 2.
Because if your game
doesn't work on that,
it might be because one of
these APIs is no longer allowed.
And it could be one
of the libraries
that you're bundling, in one of
the plug-ins you're bundling,
one of the SDKs that
you're bundling along
with it that's causing it.
So I highly, highly
recommend testing on DP2.
With DP1, we would
throw up a toast
when these things happened.
With DP2 it will get logged
in logcat and the Apple Crash.
And what will happen
in the released version
is probably
something in between.
So I'm not guaranteeing--
just because something crashes
in DP2 doesn't mean
it's going to crash.
So if you have a problem
with it, and you're saying,
hey, this middleware doesn't
work, report it to us.
File an issue.
And we might not
actually make that crash
in the final version.
But if no one
files these issues,
it's likely to go out as it is.
So this is just something
you should know.
Please, please,
please, please, please
test it against
Developer Preview 2.
It will be coming
out very shortly.
You can also use this
strict mode VM policy
to actually detect whether your
app is doing any non-SDK usage.
So this is great.
Even if you don't
have the source
code for a bunch of the
plug-ins, you can run this.
This will work on
Android P Preview 2,
and this will allow you
to actually see, OK,
does my game actually do this
even though I don't really
realize it is?
We also have this
site we've put up
on DAC to help you
transform your app or game
to the new target SDK rules.
It's a pretty good
thing to check out.
We've spent some time on it.
So hopefully most of the
information I shared here
is review for you.
Hopefully most of
you are already
targeting relatively
recent SDK versions,
but if you haven't, this
should hopefully help.
And that's it for me.
So I hope this was informative,
and thank you very much.
And I can--
I've got a couple of
minutes for questions, yeah.
If we could get the mic over.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One thing to add for
the target SDK version is also
the 64-bit in 2019.
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
So I'm actually
going to have-- yeah,
so this is another
really important thing.
I'm going to have
my colleague, Dan,
who's going to come later,
who's from the NDK team,
is going to talk about
this, is that this year it's
targeting O. Next year it will
be targeting P and targeting--
every app that has
a native component
will have to have a
64-bit binary shipped
alongside any other
binaries you want to ship.
So if you want to just ship
64-bit, you can do that,
but it's something that's
been needed to happen.
A lot of-- the future is 64-bit.
AUDIENCE: And then
the other question I
had was about
notification channels.
Are we going to see a
way to actually prompt
those categories within the
actual notification system
OS, within the app itself,
as opposed to directing users
to Settings to customize those?
DAN GALPIN: That's
a good question.
I don't think so.
Not yet.
But I know that
they're going to talk
a little bit about
notifications,
how they're revamping this--
the notification channel stuff--
tomorrow.
So I definitely recommend
watching a little bit
on that in the What's
New in Android talk.
Anything else?
Yes.
I can repeat the question, too.
AUDIENCE: Any chance we
can get a link to that?
DAN GALPIN: A link?
AUDIENCE: To the slideshow?
DAN GALPIN: Oh, sorry.
Actually, this one
got recorded, too.
So we'll have that up later--
soon, hopefully.
But also, I'm giving a
version of this talk which
is slightly less focused on game
developers at I/O on Thursday.
So there'll be a
livestream to that,
and that will actually
probably get up
even faster than this one.
It'll have a few other--
it'll have a bunch
of corny jokes,
and it will have
a few other things
that I can't talk about now.
So it might be
worth checking out
as well, the I/O presentation.